this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by our new card game Go Heckle
fish yes that's a
thing in September
1964 Captain McLoy and Sergeant Barnes
were dispatched from Wright Patterson
Air Force Base in Ohio they were sent to
investigate a UFO sighting in Northern
California rright Patterson AFB got lots
of UFO reports 99% of them could be
explained and a sizable percentage of
those were just hoaxers looking for
attention the other 1% were classified
as UFOs and sent on to Project Blue Book
what happened from there McLoy didn't
know the fact that he was being sent to
the other side of the country meant this
sighting was important to the Air Force
mloa had a copy of the teletype report
from the UFO tracking office it was
stamped with an unusual priority
notification it read UFO landing with
entities reported by missile technician
in Tahoe NF Sacramento orders
investigate and contain via usual
protocols ASAP mcl's First Step was to
interview the witness and even after 17
years as an investigator this was the
strangest UFO story he'd ever
[Music]
heard D D D D D D D D D d
d here you are sir beler Martini shake
and not stir pearl onions yeah thank you
honey uh grab a chip off my stack and
get yourself something nice would you
got it
girl ah new face at my table may I join
you Mr P James Pond go ahead take a load
off I'm Dr human the owner of this
establishment
Mery you seem to be down a few chips Mr
Pond I hope you're finding our tables
Fair yeah you know what they say about
chips don't you it's not the size of the
stack that counts it's how you slide it
in a
pot besides I heard this is the best
casino in Monaco flattery may work out
there Mr P but in here it's your bets
that count would you and your small
stack care to graze the
staks fores Fortuna juat well judging by
your lack of Fortune your buness does
not seem to be working tonight don't
worry about me I got good instincts for
the game yeah but instincts can be
deceptive Mr Pond especially in
unfamiliar vs I'm no stranger to
swimming with sharks Dr human yeah but
not all predators are created equal Mr
Pond there's always a bigger
fish and that's why I carry a big hook
and I got the biggest worm you've ever
seen and if I bite Mr Pond are you fish
enough to rail me in that is only one
way to find out do you have any
[Music]
Cryptids go ah heck and fish hey it's
your buddy a and me and Heckle fish and
we're excited to announce our new card
game Go Heckle fish the deck of 52
uniquely Illustrated cards features your
favorite characters from the wi files
and the after files live stream
categories include Cryptids monoliths
coverup Shadow People relics aliens and
more but watch out for the two special
bonus cards The elusive crab cat a crab
cat can instantly turn the tide of the
game feed a crab cat go Heckle fish is
perfect for Game Nights With Friends
family and kids of all ages grab a deck
now for only 25 bucks too much grab a
deck now for 20 bucks still too much 15
that works for only $15 grab your go
Heckle fish cards today and experience
the wi files like never before amount of
fun may vary Heckle fish does his own
voice who does your voice P the crab cat
not
[Music]
guaranteed well Mr Pond I'm afraid luck
wasn't on your side tonight pity I was
expecting more from a fish with your
reputation oh yes I may have only one
eye but I see much
double but your one I didn't see this
[Music]
coming how you fear the crab
kit you may have once this round Mr
pardon but we will meet
again
[Music]
but if this stupid commercial gets a lot
of views you can count on
[Music]
it it was a Friday morning September 4th
1964 When Donald shum set out for the
woods Don and his two friends Vincent
Alvarez and Tim TR blood were headed to
Cisco Grove it was about 3/4 of the way
to Lake Tahoe 80 Mi or so about an hour
hour and a half drive the three men
worked for aerojet Corporation a
military subcontractor in Sacramento Dom
was a welder and specifically worked on
Polaris and Titan nuclear missiles a
stressful job a weekend with friends bow
hunting deer in the Tahoe national
forest was just what he needed to clear
his head Firearms were prohibited in the
National Forest this time of year and
that suited Don just fine he was a
skilled Bow Hunter he preferred the bow
over a rifle anyway it felt like real
hunting it it was quiet peaceful even as
long as he's not hunting with hooks and
worms he's all right by me the men
quickly set up camp hit the forest and
fanned out they had no communication
equipment so they had to stay within
shouting distance they had an agreement
that if anyone got separated by
Nightfall they would return to the
campsite by Sunset Don hadn't spotted
any deer as he decided to head back to
Camp he realized he got turned around at
some point he was lost he shouted for
his friends but didn't get a reply
being out in the woods alone at night
wasn't a good idea other Hunters had
reported bears and other predators in
the area but it was getting dark and the
temperature was dropping Don had no
choice he'd be staying in the woods that
night but there was no way he was doing
it at ground level Don made for High
Ground found a massive pine tree rooted
on a cliff side and started climbing H
you see I normally think it's stupid you
came from monkeys H but I got to admit
sometimes it comes in handy Don had a
military type belt that could serve as a
harness he found a strong branch and
secured himself he was high enough that
a bear or wild cat would have to work to
reach him but they could reach him so
he'd have to stay awake all night Don
was fighting sleep when he saw a light
through the trees he assumed that his
friends had reported him missing and
this was the forest service sending out
a rescue helicopter he scrambled down
the tree and lit a couple of signal
fires he built he started shouting and
waving his arms by the time the light
was Within about 50 yard Don realized it
wasn't making any sound it wasn't a
[Music]
helicopter the light floated silently
and slowly approached Don's location he
quickly put out the signal fires and
climbed back up the tree it was dark and
he was wearing all camouflage his plan
was stay still stay quiet and wait for
the light to pass the light was small
maybe 8 or 10 in across at first Don
thought this was a tiny spacecraft the
light moved slowly and silently then the
light started swaying it was scanning
the area the motion of the light allowed
Don to make out the shape of the craft
it wasn't small the ship was an enormous
black cylinder 150 ft long the size of a
14-story building lying on its side the
beam of light was searching the canyon
the trees the large rocks in the area
then the light
stopped on the hull of The Craft Don saw
three horizontal slits of light appear
the slits expanded into tall narrow
rectangles of light they were windows or
doors opening on the side of the craft
then from the middle window there was a
flash of light and a dark object shot
down the canyon it was another smaller
Ship by this point Don was terrified a
few seconds later the small ship floated
up to the ridg line near Don's tree and
came to a stop he could see a blinking
light on top of it it was shaped like a
flying sauc that he'd seen in pictures
Don was doing everything he could to
remain still but he was trembling the
silence made the experience worse he
could hear the sound of the wind blowing
up from the canyon and hitting the trees
but the loudest sound was his blood
pumping through his ears he hadn't
believed in UFOs or aliens or any of
that he considered himself a regular guy
he was a welder by trade on the weekends
he enjoyed hiking hunting or just
hanging out with his family this was the
last thing he expected d didn't move he
had to remind himself to breathe he
looked at his hands and he was squeezing
his bow so tightly that his knuckles had
turned white 5 minutes went by and it
was an eternity then Don heard branches
breaking and bushes rustling something
was forcing its way through the brush
and headed right for his
[Music]
tree for the next 2 or 3 minutes The
Stomping and scraping got louder and
louder whatever this was it was was
getting closer the sound stopped two
shapes emerged from the brush at the
tree line stood a pair of beings
humanoid but definitely not human they
were between four and 5 ft tall wearing
silver suits Don couldn't make out their
faces but he could see they were wearing
some kind of eyewear he thought they
resembled welding goggles the beings
seemed interested in the surroundings
they were carefully picking leaves and
placing bits of soil into tubes with
long slender fingers they slowly walked
in the direction of Don's tree he
instinctively tightened his belt that
was wrapped around a large Branch the
being stopped and Don held his breath
then he saw the two creatures slowly
tilting their heads back as they scanned
up the tree they must have heard him
then they saw him within the goggles he
saw large round eyes that dominated the
being's faces their eyes locked with his
and they walked toward him and stopped
at the base of the tree Dom wasn't up
all that high maybe 10 to 12 ft off the
ground if these beings reached toward
him or could jump in any way they could
get to him the beings looked at each
other and made sounds that sounded like
the hooting of an owl then they looked
back at da he felt a wave of panic wash
over him he couldn't tell if they meant
him harm or what their intentions were
at all he just stared at them and tried
not to move a few seconds later he heard
more crashing through the trees bushes
were bending and breaking whatever was
coming was big and it was heavy a third
figure appeared at the tree line it was
casting a large Shadow and moving
mechanically it was a robot wait wait
wait wait wait did you just say it was a
robot well we don't know for sure it was
basically the same size and shape as the
humanoids maybe a little taller Don
later described it as looking like and
moving like a robot it stopped under
Don's tree between the two smaller
beings it looked like a robot from Pulp
magazines it was about 6 ft tall and
metallic it had a boxy torso and a
square head it had no neck and a square
jaw when it opened its mouth the entire
jaw opened it like the iron shant
exactly like that just scale down the
robot had reddish orange eyes that
glowed like flashlights in the dark it
was looking at him the two humanoids HED
again and the ship sounded a reply as if
responding the robot's arm lifted and
its metallic hand adjusted its jaw the
robot angled its face towards Dawn its
mouth opened and there was a loud hiss
there was a jet of white smoke like
Steam from a kettle then Don felt the
vapor hitting his facea Ora well Don's
brain told him to react but his muscles
didn't respond he was paralyzed Inda his
vision got blurry then everything went
[Music]
black Don woke up slumped over the
branch it's a good thing his belt was
firmly attached or he would have fallen
out of the tree he shook off the
paralysis and was hit with a wave of
nausea he looked down and the beings
were trying to climb after him Don was
dry heaving as he inched higher up the
tree the robot reached for its jaw again
preparing another attack and Don
considered this an escalation he grabbed
an arrow knocked it and Drew back his
bow he aimed for the chest of the robot
it was only 8 or 10 ft away at this
distance an arrow from a 60 lb bow moves
as fast as a bullet from a rifle he let
it fly a fraction of a second later the
arrow hit the robot Square in the chest
there was a bright flash of Sparks as
the robot stumbled backward the
humanoids retreated to the tree line it
worked then the robot steadied itself
along with the beings it returned to the
base of the tree it raised its arm
opened its mouth there was a hiss and
another blast of white Vapor Don inched
a little higher but he couldn't breathe
it was like there was no air he felt
himself black out again when he came two
the humanoids were trying to figure out
how to get him out of the tree again KN
he grabbed another arrow he drew back as
far as he could he released the arrow
again he hit the robot square and again
there were Sparks and again it stumbled
backward the humanoids also retreated
before the robot could get its balance
Don hit it Square in the chest again
this time it almost lost its balance and
fell over but it didn't it regained its
footing and started back toward the tree
I keep shooting that thing but Don
reached for his quiver it was empty he
was out of
[Music]
arrows Don woke up and wretched he
wasn't sure how long he was out but the
humanoids were now climbing a rock next
to the tree they hooted and the robot
lifted its arm Don patted his pockets
matches he grabbed his baseball cap and
set it on fire he threw this at the
robot and all three stepped backward Don
then started lighting everything he had
on fire he tore pieces off his jacket
lit those on fire and sent them down
again he was hit with vapor and knocked
out and this went on for hours Tom was
knocked out by the gas over and over
again but he kept burning things and
dropping them down he burned every bit
of clothing he had except the shirt and
jeans shoes socks gloves everything gone
which could be a problem it was getting
cold the fires would give him a few
seconds to adjust his position but not
enough time to get out of range of the
vapor then the matches ran out he threw
everything he had at the creatures his
quiver his Compass his canteen all he
had left were a few coins and he threw
those too after waking up from another
Vapor attack Dawn saw a hint of orange
in the clouds the sun would be up in an
hour but he didn't know if he could
survive that long he was exhausted and
he was out of options he thought about
his wife and daughter as he passed out
again Don opened his eyes and the
humanoids were gone no but now there
were two robots at the base of the tree
oh no arcs of electricity bounced
between them like a Jacob's Ladder they
were pooling their energy both robots
reached for their jaws and open their
mouths Don tried to scramble higher but
the air around him suddenly got so cold
he choked he couldn't breathe he knew it
was almost over he felt himself blacking
out as he was losing Consciousness he
wondered if they'd ever find his body
who would be at his
funeral he thought to himself this is
going to be hard on my little girl then
a cloud of cold white smoke hit him Dom
was right it was
over when Don woke up he was hanging off
the tree by his belt arms and legs
dangling the sun was up he was alone he
made it Don carefully adjusted his belt
and slowly came down from the tree he
grabbed his compass and headed back to
Camp Barefoot freezing and exhausted he
told his friends what happened they
believed him one of them saw the ship
too and when Don got home he told his
family what happened now his
mother-in-law wait wait wait what he
told the Mother-in-law always a mistake
well he told his wife and she told the
Mother-in-law women what communication
is important in a
marriage you poor simple bastard anyway
his mother-in-law knew an astronomy
professor at a local community college
she thought his science background could
help him explain the lights the object
and what happened a couple of weeks
later Don spoke to the professor and
recounted every detail he could the
professor thought this event was
important and decided to contact the
nearby mlen Air Force Base everyone's
got a big mouth in this story the
professor gave the Air Force a summary
of Don's story and the location of the
incident within days two investigators
were sent from Wright Patterson AFB in
Ohio captain mcloyd and Sergeant Barnes
they didn't want to meet Don at his
house instead they met him at a vacant
rental in the area they told Don to come
alone he did the only things in the
house were a table and two chairs
sketchy well they just wanted to control
the area and hear Don's story without
his family around yeah I like it well
remember Don worked at a highly secure
nuclear missile facility the air force
needed to get to the bottom of this yeah
I don't trust these guys yeah well they
brought along a bulky real toore tape
recorder and extensively documented
Don's entire 12-hour encounter the
investigators asked Donald detailed
questions about the creatures what did
they look like their height skin texture
clothing how did they move what
abilities or tools did they have they
asked specifics about the large ship its
shape visible features like lights and
markings how did it maneuver they asked
Don how he fought back against the
attack how effective he was and which
creatures he targeted they asked for a
detailed map of the area what was the
elevation topology what kind of rocks
and trees were there after after they
had all the details and chronology of
events the investigator switched into
interrogation mode and here we
[Music]
go the friendly investigators weren't so
friendly anymore the investigators
became interrogators and they came at
Don hard time the lawyer up Chief they
offered alternative scenarios for what
happened were there weapon tests going
on lawyer was Don intoxicated on drugs
or alcohol lawyer was this actually
teenagers playing an elaborate prank
lawyer could this have been Japanese
soldiers that Don mistook for aliens
Japanese soldiers yep in the woods in
the middle of the night yeah Don said
that was ridiculous he saw what he saw
he was telling the truth he even showed
them an arrow head that had bits of
metal on it from the impact with the
robot the Air Force took the arrow as
evidence and he never saw it again and
he never saw it again the investigators
left and did not follow up during rifle
season Don went back to the area where
the encounter happened there was an
orange circle around the tree the whole
area had been raked clean for about 50
feet around the tree there were still
rake marks in the dirt and a few
cigarette butts around the perimeter it
was obvious the Air Force was there and
cleaned everything up soon after that
Don developed anxiety he suffered severe
PTSD including walking nightmares for
about a year hearing owl sounds would
trigger a panic attack his welding
skills declined he was fired from his
job and his family almost went bankrupt
he could have sold his story or wrote a
book yeah but he didn't want his name
attached to this his neighbors thought
he was crazy he thought he was crazy his
family had to move in with relatives in
Arizona and the only work he could find
was low wage the event ruined Don's life
and he wanted nothing more to do with it
he tried to put it out of his mind and
slowly he was able to recover he was
finally free of the Cisco Grove UFO
encounter then 14 years later the phone
rang Don's case resurfaced when groups
like naikap and muam were going through
old files his was intriguing enough to
attract the attention of Hollywood Don
story ended up on an NBC special called
project UFO Paul cery an investigator
for naikap filed a freedom of
information request and it took a couple
of years but they finally released the
file the file said what Don experienced
didn't happened the report said the
incident was psychologically based and
dismissed it as a hoax or a delusion but
the file also contained a signed
affidavit from Vincent Alvarez who said
he saw a craft descending toward Don's
area at the time of the event in the mid
2000s Don finally started talking about
the event in 2011 a book was published
aliens in the forest The Cisco Grove UFO
encounter though Don story was now
available to the public it's one of the
Lesser known UFO stories h g knew about
it oh yeah we got the story from Gino
story hour if you want to hear his take
on it there's a link below he gets into
it he does but did it really happen Don
story has been consistent for 50 years
he's never tried to capitalize on it the
opposite happened this encounter broke
him financially and psychologically
there's also the other eyewitness
Vincent Alvarez who said he saw the ship
and the Air Force did send investigators
across the country to look into this
they did admit took something from Don
presumably the arrow or Arrowhead on the
other side there's no actual physical
evidence the Air Force never return the
arrow Don said they cleaned up the site
and if they did they didn't document
this or test the soil for radiation or
anything like that that we know of well
true the Air Force did want to keep this
quiet but these creatures had
anti-gravity technology yet they
couldn't figure out how to climb a tree
why not fly the smaller ship over and I
don't like that the beings and the robot
are described exactly like 1960 sci-fi
that makes me skeptical also Don said
Moonlight helped him see the ship but
there was no moon that night Don said he
found another one of his arrows but we
don't know if it was tested or what
happened to it was the Cisco Grove UFO
encounter real well it was real enough
to Donald Trump it destroyed his life he
lost everything and almost lost his mind
but the Air Force said that he lost his
mind before the encounter a 12-hour life
or death struggle with aliens a man
stuck in a tree firing arrows at a vapor
shooting robot a government
investigation and cover up you have
enough information to decide if it's
true but one thing is for sure it's a
great story and to me it's all that
[Music]
matters thank you so much for hanging
out with me today my name is AJ that's
Heckle fish yo mama this has been the wi
files if you had fun or learned anything
do us a favor subscribe like comment
share that stuff really helps the
channel and like most topics we cover on
the channel today's topic is recommended
by you so if there's a story you'd like
to see or learn more about go to the Wi
files.com tips and remember the yfiles
is also a podcast twice a week I post
deep dives into the stories we cover
here on the channel I also post episodes
that wouldn't be allowed on the channel
it's called the wi files operation
podcast and it's available everywhere
you get your podcasts and if you need
more wi- files in your life cuz who
doesn't check out our Discord there are
thousands of people on there 24/7 and
they're into the same weird stuff that
we are it's a great community and it's a
lot of fun and it's free to join and
special thanks to our patrons who make
every episode possible I don't deserve
your support but I'm truly grateful for
it and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon for as little as three bucks a
month you get access to perks like you
can see videos early with no commercials
you get access to merch only available
to Members Plus you get two private live
streams every every week just for you
another great way to support the channel
is grab something from the wifi store
grab a Heckle fish t-shirt or a mug or a
squeezy toy or one of these new decks of
go Heckle fish cards with all the
special characters and stuff on them
they're wonderful you'll love it that's
going to do it until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh oh
yeah I play Bia Scara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my PR
and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I being
only true
aware dud standle CU brick fake the moon
landing alone on a film set I with the
shadow be over
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish on thday night Wednesday
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth to the W all through the
[Music]
night the MTH man SIDS and the solar
stor still come to have got the the
secret City
Underground serious number stations
Planet Sero to project Star Gate and
where the dark Watchers
[Music]
found a simulation don't
you the black KN satell lighted to so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the fish
heck fish on thday night Wednesday J
when through the
night
all I ever wanted was to just hear the
truth so the I'm Fe all through the
night fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
and all through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the one Fe all through
the
good love to dance good love to dance
good love to dance good
dance loves to
dance good loves to dance on the dance
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on
way in time good love Dan good love
dance
[Music]
oh